one thing that that people do not care
about this has become clear over the
past
five ten years is fighting
wars overseas for dubious purposes
what do we do when you think about the
war in afghanistan which has gone on now
what 20 years
i don't think it's a partisan issue
exactly and i think the the state
department basically wants us to be
there i think the the liberal empire
wants us to continue to have
these little wars of empire but i don't
think it's a republican issue i think a
lot of republicans want to get out of
afghanistan trump ran in 2016
on getting out of the middle east
because he said they were just big flops
they were crazy wars and was a big
mistake of george w bush
same kind of arguments that democrats
were making before that although
even barack obama for instance runs for
office on how iraq was a terrible idea
but he didn't want to be seen as a
weakling so then he decided that
afghanistan was the good war so he
he pulls out of iraq to some degree
and then he restarts the war in
afghanistan that had basically been
winding down
because he needed he needed to have a
good war so joe biden right now
is seeing which way the political winds
are blowing
he is calling to draw down and pull out
of afghanistan a continuation of what
trump was trying to do
and saki was asked about this said so
what were we
doing what did we win what was what's
the goal what are we doing in
afghanistan
and jenn saki cannot say that we declare
victory in terms of plans for the end
for our men and women coming back i
don't have anything to preview but we
don't we're not going to have a mission
accomplished moment
in this regard it's a 20-year
war that has not been won militarily we
are
proud of the men and women who have
served uh incredibly grateful
the president will note that in his
remarks today how grateful he is for
uh their service and the families who
have sacrificed
uh over the last 20 years and we will
continue to press for
a political outcome and a political
solution but uh beyond that i think
we're going to continue to look for ways
to
communicate why we make the choice
choices we make
the mission accomplished has this
mission not been accomplished
well i would say we did exactly what we
wanted to do what i was referring to
jeff is uh we're not um having a moment
of celebration
uh we're having a moment where we feel
it's in our national security interest
to bring our men and women
serving home wait wait wait hold on i i
got it
i got it at the first part when you said
look this has been a 20-year war
it's a complex war and there's not going
to be a mission accomplished moment like
george w bush had with iraq before
we realized that mission had not been
accomplished yet but then you then you
said wait the mission has been
accomplished
we did what we set out to do what was
that what did we set out to do
if what we set out to do was kill osama
bin laden then i guess that mission was
accomplished but then what were we
staying there for afterward
if the mission was to defeat terrorists
in well terrorism really sprung up in
iraq and syria right with the rise of
isis
so what was going on in afghanistan if
the mission was to get rid of the
taliban that just didn't work because
the taliban are coming back in
what was the mission
the mission was whatever the foreign
policy establishment wanted at the time
the mission was whatever the state
department wanted at the time
i think the american people are just as
confused about this sort of thing
as gensake appears to be and that
is a big problem i think we've got to be
much clearer when
when when dr fauci says get over it
get over your political objections
having the government force you all to
get a vaccine is not political
good grief he just he has this
progressive conception of the political
which is so so desiccated
a public act such as mass government
compelled vaccination
is by definition a political act but he
just when he says it's not political
what he's saying is you have no right to
have an opinion about it
and for too long that has been not just
the case in public health it's been true
in foreign policy that's been true in
trade policy
you're just not allowed to have an
opinion you're you're just not one of
the smart people you don't get it these
trade deals that are going to hollow out
the manufacturing in america
they're they're like obviously true
they're the best
okay and you have no right to question
that you're just a deplorable
irredeemable idiot
you owe you you're questioning the wars
overseas you just don't get it you just
don't
leave it to the experts okay leave it to
the state department leave it to dr
fauci
leave it to the administrative state
leave it to the
trade negotiators leave it to the wto
leave it to
leave it to everyone but you get over
self-government that's what they're
telling you to do
i don't want to get over self-government
although our elected leaders are not
exactly instilling confidence joe biden
tried to answer some questions about
what was going on in afghanistan
didn't go well for the release of
detained americans including
uh mark uh uh scheming
ferris i i want to pronounce the name
correctly i miss
i misspoke and this starting this month
we're going to begin to re
re reloca we're going to begin
relocation flights
for afghanistan siv applicants uh half
have gotten on aircraft and come
commercial flights and come and other
halves believe they want to stay
we went for two reasons one
to
bring osama bin laden to the gates of
hell
as i said at the time i'm not even going
to make fun of this this is extremely
sad and pathetic and the man is
obviously not up to being president
and this is probably why the
establishment just continues
to rule and rule that's why joe biden
refers to they
all the time well they told me to say
this they didn't let me say this they
don't want me to do that
the man clearly cannot do
the job hey there i'm glad you like that
clip you can get the whole
episode called getting over
self-government here
you don't even look if you ring the bell
and subscribe you'll get the
notifications you won't need me to tell
you
things like this you can go get that
episode you can also get it on apple
podcasts everywhere else you get your
your podcasts
you can also get my book the number one
national best-selling speechless sold
many many more copies than the number
one bestseller on the new york times
list but we're very proud to be snubbed
by the new york times thank you very
much to everyone who's read it
thanks for leaving a review we'll see
you next time